♪
♪.
AISHAH: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW" TEXAS IS BRACING
FOR A MASSIVE SURGE OF 60000
MIGRANTS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WHICH COULD BE THE LARGEST GROUP
EVER TO ATTEND TO ILLEGALLY
ENTER THE UNITED STATES FROM
MEXICO.
ADMIT A RECORD SURGE OF ILLEGALS
APPREHENDED AT THE BOARD OF THE
DHS TERMINATED THE BORDER WALL
CONTRACT IN LAREDO AND RIO
GRANDE VALLEY, FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP STARTED THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE BORDER WALL AND DATA
RALLY HE NAMED THE BORDER CRISIS
AS ONE OF MANY.
>> AFTER NINE MONTHS UNDER
BIDEN, VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND
BLOODTHIRSTY GANGS ARE TAKING
OVER OUR STREETS, ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND DEADLY DRUG CARTELS ARE
TAKING OVER OUR BORDERS,
INFLATION IS TAKING OVER OUR
ECONOMY, CHINA IS TAKING OVER
OUR JOBS, THE TALIBAN HAS TAKEN
OVER AFGHANISTAN.
LUNATIC LEFTIST ARE TAKING OVER
OUR SCHOOLS AND RADICAL
SOCIALIST ARE TAKING OVER OUR
COUNTRY.
AS DISASTROUS AS ABIDED
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN, NO ONE
CAN BLAME THE GREAT STATE OF
IOWA BECAUSE BOY, WE DID REALLY
GOOD HERE.
AISHAH: THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD
RUNDOWN AND FOR A PRESIDENT FOR
US RIGHT NOW WHO CAMPAIGNED ON
BEING A UNIFIER, IT SEEMS AS IF
HE'S DEDICATED TO TWO THINGS,
INCOMPETENCE AND ALSO ABSOLUTELY
DISMANTLING EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT THE PRIOR PRESIDENT PUT IN
PLACE, INCLUDING OF COURSE ALL
OF THE BORDER WALL CONTRACTS.
IT SEEMS HE IS IGNORING ANY
PRIOR PROGRAM OR POLICY THAT WAS
ACTUALLY SERVING WELL AND GOOD
REGARDLESS OF WHAT PARTY IS
IDENTIFIED WITH THE PERSON
BEHIND PUTTING A POLICY IN
PLACE, WHAT YOU SEE HAPPENING
THAT IS DETERMINING ALL THE
BORDER WALL CONTRACTS?
SPEAKER IS THAT FOR ME?
, I'M SO DISTRACTED BY HOW WELL
WE ARE MATCHING.
A POLL RELEASED LAST WEEK WAS
DEVASTATING IT SHOWS THE BIDEN
HARRIS ADMINISTRATION IS PULLING
23% APPROVAL ON THEIR HANDLING
OF THE BORDER AND I WOULD LOVE
TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE STRAWBERRY,
23% SOMEHOW THEY THINK THEY'RE
GOING WELL, AND THIS URGES TO
YOUR POINT IT IS ONLY
INCREASING, THE PRESIDENT CAN
TRAVEL 23 TIMES TO DELAWARE
SINCE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR BUT
IS YET TO TRAVEL TO THE BORDER
IN THE 50 YEARS IN GOVERNMENT
ALL THIS WHILE HIS VICE
PRESIDENT WHO ONCE COMPARED ICE
TO THE KKK IS MIA AT THE BORDER,
WTF, NOT LOL AS WE GO FULL
ACCURATE ON THIS.
THEY WOULD NOT CONTINUE TO MAKE
EVERY WRONG DECISION ON SECURING
THE BORDER AND BRING INSANITY
BACK TO ENFORCING THE LAWS AND
THE BOOKS BUT SURE ENOUGH THEY
WON'T LEAVING SOME ON THE RIGHT
AS IT'S BECOMING A FAIR
QUESTION, I THOUGHT IT WASN'T AT
FIRST BUT HOW DO YOU IGNORE
2.5 MILLION PEOPLE COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY, IS THIS INTENTIONAL
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE IT DOES
NOT SEEMED LIKE THEY HAVE ANY
INTEREST IN FIXING THIS PROBLEM
BEFORE WHEN THERE'S A NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD THERE IS SO MUCH
NEGLIGENCE IT BECOMES CRIMINAL
AND ABSOLUTELY LUDICROUS.
AS WE WERE JUST TALKING OBAMA
AGO THIS ADMINISTRATION
MAINTAINS THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
IS COVID, THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
IS MANAGING EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT FLOWS FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE RESTRICTED
SOMEBODY LIBERTIES AND FREEDOMS
AND THE LIKE, HOW DOES THAT FIT
IN WITH THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
IGNORING WHAT IS OCCURRING ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, THE ALMOST
15000 HAITIAN MIGRANTS THAT
SURGED ACROSS-THE-BOARD IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS.
THAT IS LESS THAN 1% VACCINATION
RATE, THIS ADMINISTRATION ALLOWS
FOR ALL THE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
COMING IN TO OVER 30%
VACCINATION DECLINATION RATE,
THE SPREAD OF THE TRANSMISSION
IS OVER 6%.
THEY CLOSE NEW YORK CITY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AT 3%, HOW DOES THAT
EVEN FIT MAINTAINING THE COVID
AT THE HIGHEST PRIORITY.
AISHAH: THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
PROBLEM, I THINK EVERYONE CAN
AGREE OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR THESE
PEOPLE IN THE POSITION THAT THEY
ARE PUT IN AS THEY CROSS THE
BORDER.
SITTING NEXT TO EACH OTHER UNDER
A BRIDGE AS WE SAW NOT TOO LONG
AGO AND ALSO THE WAY THE CARTEL
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
SITUATION I HAVE BEEN DOWN THERE
TWICE AND OBVIOUSLY I'VE SEEN
THE EQUIPMENT AND THE MATERIALS
TO BUILD A BORDER WALL JUST
SITTING THERE ROTTING AWAY AND
OBVIOUSLY WE FOUND OUT THROUGH
OUR BRILLIANT BRET BAIER THAT WE
WERE SPENDING $5 MILLION A DAY
TO NOT BUILD A BORDER WALL.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
NOT FORGET THAT THE PROBLEM THAT
WERE NOT CONFRONTING RIGHT NOW
ARE THE CARTELS THAT IS WHAT YOU
WOULD HEAR FROM THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS AND HENRY CUELLAR
A CONGRESSMAN FROM THIS DISTRICT
TO IS A DEMOCRAT, NOT FOR THE
BORDER WALL BUT FOR BORDER
SECURITY WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
OF THIS MONEY THAT IS NOW GOING
TO BE DIVERTED SOMEWHERE ELSE
AND SPENT ON TECHNOLOGY AND
FINDING WAYS TO BETTER PROTECT
THE BORDER FROM THE CARTELS
WHETHER THAT IS CAMERAS OR
LIGHTING OR ADDING MORE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS BUT WE REALLY NEED
TO CENTER THE CONVERSATION BACK
ON THE CARTELS BECAUSE THE
CARTELS ARE REALLY TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE SITUATION IN
ADVANTAGE OF ALL THAT THESE
PEOPLE THAT EVENTUALLY SOME WILL
BE TRAFFICKED.
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO LIVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM ONCE THEY GET
INTO THIS COUNTRY AND WILL BE
ABUSED.
EMILY: THERE IS A COMPLEX WEB OF
FACTORS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
NOT LEAST OF WHICH THE HUMAN
SMUGGLING INDUSTRY WHICH IS THE
LARGEST INDUSTRY BESIDES DRUGS.
THE CARTELS ARE FREELY SEIZING
UPON PUSHING SO MANY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
BORDER, A REIGN OF TERROR WE
HAVE A COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WHO
TOUTED HIS 50 YEAR EXPERIENCE IN
GOVERNMENT AS PART OF HIS
INTERNATIONAL SAVVY AS A
DIPLOMACY REQUIRED TO WORK WITH
MEXICO AND CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES IN GOVERNMENT TO HELP
MANAGE THE INTERNATIONAL
CARTELS, NOTHING IS HAPPENING IN
OTHER DISMANTLING CONTRACTS AND
PUTTING THE MONEY TOWARDS
ENVIRONMENTAL SECTORS, YOU
CANNOT MAKE THIS UP.
GUY: THE POLICIES ARE JUST
BREATHTAKING, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ECONOMY RIGHT NOW WE HAVE VERY
DISAPPOINTING JOB NUMBERS THAT
CAME OUT ON FRIDAY, GROWTH NOT
THE EXPECTATION, WE HAVE
INFLATION HATING AMERICANS IN
THEIR POCKETBOOKS AND THEIR
BOTTOM LINES, THE POLICY
SOLUTION FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND THE WHITE HOUSE ON
THOSE FRIENDS ARE TO RAISE TAXES
ON JOB CREATORS AND TRILLIONS OF
MORE DOLLARS IN AN AGE OF
INFLATION THOSE ARE TO ME
SHOCKINGLY BAD IDEAS UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE BUT ESPECIALLY
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES YOU
APPLY THAT TO THE BORDER IN THE
CRISIS THAT WE ARE SEEING, WHAT
ARE THE THINGS THAT BIDEN HAS
BEEN AT THE BORDER.
NUMBER ONE HE HAS NOW STOPPED
AND CUT OFF ALL FUNDING AND
CONTRACTS FOR BUILDING A
BARRIER, A WALL AND I THINK
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TRUMP OR HIS
SLOGAN AND THEY WANT TO DISTANCE
THEMSELVES FROM BUILDING THE
WALL BECAUSE OF THE TRIBALISM
BUT WHEN YOU WATCH PEOPLE
WALKING ACROSS INTO OUR COUNTRY
IT IS HARD TO ARGUE THAT SOME
BARRIER WALL WOULD NOT HELP BUT
THEY WILL NOT DO THAT BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL REASONS AND SECONDLY
THEY HAVE CANCELED AND
TERMINATED THE REMAINING MEXICO
POLICY WHICH IS THE SINGLE MOST
SUCCESSFUL TRUMP AIR POLICIES ON
THE BOOKS THAT HELPED GET A
PREVIOUS CRISIS UNDER CONTROL
AND THEY'VE ABANDONED IT
ENTIRELY EVEN THOUGH IT IS ON
ITS FACE AND MANIFESTLY WORKED,
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN THAT,
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THEY PUT
POLITICS AHEAD OF SUCCESSFUL
POLICY AND IT IS EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING THING TO WAT